exactly
in the in the station and then going
back to your boyfriend and eat you out
yeah
is we exaggerate those sides of
ourselves and it's we're pushed to and
I'm not making an excuse for it at all
because yeah I agree that's it's not
great Behavior but it's because we've
been um pushed to align ourselves with
one side either hypersexual or hyperpure
and it's because it's been constantly
separated over time that we have to
align ourselves with that I'm not saying
it's a good thing I'm not saying that's
good at all but it happens and I think
it takes a certain level of
Consciousness to be able to step out of
that which not a lot of people have
access so so to me I just think girls
like attention and so so but I'm saying
I think girls especially like we live
off of attention that's why so many
girls are addicted to social media where
men are addicted to video games would
you say and so and so what I would say
is like girls that tend to be more
sexual got the attention from guys and
they liked it and they kept doing it and
that was like the positive feedback loop
but they didn't realize there was
consequences later and the girls that
didn't do that saw that there was saw
that they had the negative consequences
and therefore got the positive feedback
loop maybe had the a dad to tell them
not to do it completely but exactly
you're making it back to the father if a
father figure isn't presence to build
that strong relationship with masculine
energy a woman is going to seek out that
attention that's true that's true yeah
exactly yeah exactly yeah
but that's why that's why the father
that's why the father is so important in
the home remember right yeah no and I I
think the mask I don't think it's
necessarily a father I think it's a
healthy masculine representation which
is the problem and I think it shouldn't
necessarily be restricted to it would
you say in general or family Dynamic
there are a lot of ways that people can
get those Role Models would you say in
general it's through a father like a man
yeah in general so like if we go back
and forth about exceptions we'll be
talking in circles all day but then the
father has to step up as well as the
mother but I I think men in general like
men have issues too I'm not I'm not
negating that men have issues but like I
just think men are there's a large group
of men that have no purpose because they
don't have women because modern women
are side chicks because modern women
keep sleeping up and up and up because
you know damn well that you could sleep
with a guy that would never be seen in
public with you ever like like then that
yeah and it's that's not fun but it's
just true like guys will have sex with a
hole in the wall right yeah
and you guys you ladies know that you
can be look in your words you can walk
out the house looking average and still
got her attention from it yeah men will
still give you attention and so and so
the thing is like if we keep with birth
control and the sexual Revolution it's a
smaller percentage of men that are
having all the sex so that means a
larger percentage of men are sleeping
with nobody but and and like that's what
I'm saying it starts with the women
because if women aren't creating
families like that that's right women no
no that's who yeah
and I think it was Rwanda or something
and it was basically looking at um who
like basically who got the women and it
would be the chief or whatever they were
called and then they would have they
would have multiple wives you've seen
that like all across the world right
that's never changed and they did a city
and they found that the the first wife
had the children with the man and they
were like the you know the best they
were like Queen on top children and then
the other wives who had
um babies with the a powerful man even
if they didn't have 100
exclusivity those children were better
off than
um if a woman had a baby and with a
monogamous man so that's not just in
today's society that's literally since
you're you're correct like you're
absolutely correct you could make an
argument for polygamy but the difference
was back then the women got Resources
with it so it wasn't like like nowadays
you're just giving sex for free exactly
it's like back then you got you might
not have been first wife but you could
have been third or four like in in
Muslim cultures we had a guy on here
that talked about how he had to marry
each and every wife of his and he had to
provide it they were taken care of
financially forever and so I'm not I
mean I don't I don't prefer the
polygamist stuff but if like someone
wants to do it you can make you can make
an argument for it but but the problem
is women are getting the taking sex
without the resources and so and so and
and so and so therefore they're
incentivized to get a kid off of a rich
guy
women women don't understand that you
set the standard yeah okay for men to
have sex okay and because men generally
as much as men men even know we're quite
simple creatures yeah if the pussy's
there we'll go for it yeah okay and if
you have to understand that if you're
giving it away for free like literally I
can download the app right now right and
in an hour I can have sex like sex is so
readily available from women yeah that
men no longer have to work for it if men
had to work for sex yeah we wouldn't
have half of the problems that we're
having right now but the thing but the
thing is women are giving away their
vaginas so readily so easily that men
are like ah well you know I don't have
to work for it like what the hell I'm
women and then we'll scream men are
trash but we set the standards yeah
yeah that's what it is you need to
leverage sexual access to get commitment
right just like a man you know leverages
like his commitment or his resources you
know whether that's physical protection
emotional security or Financial Security
in order to gain access like you need to
do it or we'll need to do a better job
of leveraging sexual access to get
commitment because if you're giving it
away for free then why why am I going to
commit I can get it for free and then
you go on a talk show on a dating show
with a guy that's just had sex with you
right in the morning talking about oh
yeah you know what I want to date a guy
what you just had a penis inside you
that because your vagina is so readily
available yeah you have to understand
seriously I think women need to
understand you are making your vaginas
too readily available okay and then you
cannot now complain that men are trash
because the bottom line is if you don't
set the standard if you don't set the
president because men listen men will
die free fire for [__] I'm telling you
right they will die free fire for [__]
knows right Dave has Dave has a song
Don't Die for now yeah right exactly but
the thing is if it's if you make it less
red because like I said if Dave
Chappelle said if [__] was a stock
right it it would it would plummet it
would be plummeting right now because
the market has been flooded with it
right so you have to understand that if
you flood the market with something it
no longer becomes precious I think I
think it's a bit of a laziness it no
longer becomes precious
I think that's why a vagina is not
precious anymore is there a need for it
to be precious why isn't it
there's none if you want to be a side
chick but if you want guys to commit to
you then then you don't value you don't
you don't think your body's precious
I think my body's precious sex is sex
it's something to do because you want to
enjoy it it's not because oh hey this is
like
what is this guy going to give me so I'm
going to give him this it's just like oh
I don't know one day I might want to
have sex I'll do it I don't know I don't
know about that you can create life
a little closer yeah I prefer like
you're not having sex with me like as a
woman personally like
you can just go out and be like I want
to have sex but like I if I like
definitely treat me like a princess
first like don't just like you can't
just enter and leave like I think
you can't just go down to the gas
station have sex with you I'll go back
to my boyfriend but yes we can yes yeah
some women are fine with that and that's
their prerogative and I don't think you
should there's a you shouldn't control
women who want to do that and like like
make them feel bad about it because
that's you know there's a lot of people
with Kinks out there men and women
involved who are like into that
trying to make them feel bad about all
women to be like you're all slag so do
you do you have to do do you have the
same do you have the same energy for men
that don't want to date girls with high
body counts do you have the same energy
like that's your prerogative you're
allowed to do what you want to do yeah
or because a lot of times when I see
yeah because a lot of times what I see
is like there'll be things like [__]
shaming and like shaming language when
men want to have standards but it's also
like I don't think if if you're a woman
who doesn't sleep around a lot I don't
think you would want to date a man who
sleeps around a lot I think you just
probably find someone who's on your
level of of shagging yeah a guy who
sleeps around a lot is definitely a guy
who's provided value to a particular
extent because the vast majority of guys
can't do that you know this is this is
exactly like you because you deal with
the best guys you think all guys are
like that whereas the reality is that
that's a very minute percentage of men